welcome to whatever the [ __ ] she said
it's a game made by a five-year-old it's
a mating crayon and that's about all I
know about this game oh my and I say hey
love pony :
did the best plan in the world crystal
like Kobe and Nona corticon pony coins
wait never saw gonna go get my voice I
think is so good okay so it's like an
adventure game why should we go holy
[ __ ] who are you let's go to him
oh it's orange pie of course who doesn't
love joining me god Eddie it's like got
any jars yep he has five of them oh [ __ ]
okay so we got five and what I do too
holy [ __ ] I thought it was only me let's
start with this one whoa butterfly it
doesn't really look like oh it's a title
that was solid do well I'm upside down
if he's upside down he's actually
smiling right now
say thanks here's a pony cord that's a
pony corn
okay how did I get how's that even gonna
fit what I Pink Pony going down is
happening oh I'm sorry what
so there's five gates of hell and I have
five Pony codes again oh [ __ ] crazy
dinosaur I put 40 cord in the cages oh
you son of a [ __ ] that's racist
oh she's walking back listen what I am
going to turn you into a mouse do do not
oh okay that's pretty damn cute that's
pretty cute oh yeah oh yeah squeak that
call of duty and shove it up their ass
this game is the best game oh sorry
I'm stupid it's fine a key okay I am a
tiger and I'm going to eat that bony
corn no no wait it's not a pony calm
down
no you're not no you're not
how do you yell yeah whoa what's going
on we're so smart he doesn't know that
we take it the pony car okay very good
go up my jar best laughs okay sorry
I thought something okay what do we got
in here Neven I'm in juice in your eye
and that things I don't know what were
you get the [ __ ] out of there
yeah Meyer lemons evil they didn't let's
click on this rock
Oh what the [ __ ] is that that's told our
keys look like good does a little bit
needing to go get a coke to that okay
let's just grab the [ __ ] programming
lemons oh my gosh okay let's keep going
oh oh oh yeah we have the key yeah man
the key all right whatever so whoa I got
the purple pony cone up in the jaw I got
the purple corner injured aw I got the
pony pony pony put you put the bar up or
Jupiter okay so let's get the coconut
some how can we do that oh we can genius
piss outsmarted a five-year-old that's
how I roll okay so let's take the
coconut to the thing or maybe he wants
your coconut no that's
Oh No well Emma's man what does I yeah
thanks for telling us all so it became
fatter in the jar we got one pony corner
boy go and see if he's okay
I think he was in this stream I'm really
a pony corn I changed and orange boy ah
to make sure you were nice to pony
chords I and the last bone is gone put
me in a jar [ __ ] man the story is so
good it's so thick I mean I'm so
immersing this week on universe how is
putting Pony chords in a jar nine
this morning Oh Bravo
that is saga I was that was actually
really cute and really sweet I enjoyed
that a lot more than I thought I would
and ap Bros enjoyed as well go ahead and
leave it like help me out a lot I'm
gonna link this game if you want to try
it out in the description kind of come
over today and I'll see